[Music]
so today i have the great pleasure of
speaking with
jonathan pagio whom i know primarily as
a thinker
who's a carver of orthodox icons that
are
absolutely beautiful i have one in my
house of saint michael and the dragon
and an increasingly prominent youtuber
prominent among
intellectual youtubers i would say
essentially
as particularly those who are interested
in religious and philosophical and
artistic ideas and
jonathan and i have been talking back
and forth for i would think about
six or seven years now eh we met in
2015. yeah it's
my time it's crazy time flies it's crazy
that's for sure
so i i we haven't spoken for
two years maybe yeah we saw each other i
think when you
booked him out and you came to montreal
for a little event and i picked you up
at the airport
that was the last time we saw each other
yeah it's a while
a lot of water under the bridge that's
right indeed
and in your case literally yes exactly
jonathan jonathan's house was flooded
out
that was when it was in 2019
um but we just moved back into our house
this christmas and so it was a long kind
of a long
thing it lasted a very long time so and
are you in your house right now
yes i am in my my house all fixed up and
so
we're really enjoying it we're happy to
be back i bet it must have been
unbelievably dislocating to be
flooded like that your whole basement
filled with water if i remember
correctly
yeah exactly it was a dyke broke in the
in the city and uh you know i think as
thousands of people got evacuated within
an hour and so
for my kids especially it was my kids
and even my wife it was
it was a little bit of a trauma because
it was water we could see the water
coming and there were cops and
and you know all these uh firemen and
everything and so it was a pretty
intense moment
yeah and where where were you living
when your house was underwater
we moved around we lived at my parents
then we rented a place then we had to
move and so we ended up living in three
places during the about a year and a
half that we were gone
um so but it was a it it was one of
those things where you know we say
symbolism happens you know a lot of the
things that even you talk about or that
i talk about
just manifested themselves this problem
of the dyke and the the idea of
uh you know corruption or inattention to
the situation and then thinking you're
safe when in fact you're not aware of
what's what's kind of looming on the
margins
and and so for me it was a real learning
experience i hope that i've come out of
it
stronger and more more attentive let's
say
yeah well i hope so too i mean we all
hope that we come out of
unpleasant experiences stronger than
when we went in although
that isn't always the case it's the case
when
things are functioning optimally and
when you're fortunate and courageous and
i suppose as honest as you can be but
fortunate definitely ranks high among
all of those necessary um
preconditions for successful recovery i
would say
yeah and i have to say that i am we are
i'm so grateful to see you back online
you know
that i know you've heard this but there
have been thousands of people
thinking about you praying for you and
really rooting for you and
you know uh i actually saw tammy last
year i when i went to bring your icon
and and i just remember
just feeling uh helpless and and you
know she was like
would you go to russia and i was like
i'll go to russia i'll go see jordan in
russia
it didn't seem like it was a reasonable
thing to do and and it's probably better
it didn't happen but
we've definitely been praying for you
and routing for you and thinking about
you jordan
you know i appreciate that a lot and i'm
i'm back to some degree i would say i
still think i'm running at about five
percent
so yeah and that's partly why i was
concerned about talking to you today and
we're generally discuss things that are
relatively deep and
it's still difficult for me to go
deeply into anything that's happening to
me because it's so unbelievably awful
and it's it's it's been hard on my faith
i would say
you know and it's my book is coming out
in my new book i should show it to you
i just got recognized yesterday that's
awesome to order
it's in it's unbelievable that you wrote
that during all of this i can't believe
that
when you say you're running at five
percent i think that your five percent
is
is pretty close to the hundred percent
of most people yeah well
i don't know if that's true or not but
it's five percent for me and
getting the book was actually somewhat
of a traumatic experience i would say
because it reminded me
like it's a it's a it's a
it's a concrete reminder of everything
that's happened over the last three or
four years and
it all things that i found very
difficult to process
both on the social front and on the
let's say biological
health front um so
i was reading oddly enough uh i i got a
book sent to me by bishop baron the
first draft of a book and
it's written by a couple of professors
it's called jordan peterson god and
christianity the search for a meaningful
life
by dr christopher caxor and dr matthew
pretzek
word on fire institute to catholic
response to my biblical series
and hopefully they won't be too upset
about me talking about it today but i
won't talk about it that much
the book itself it was rather a shock to
me
they're at loyola marymount university
and it was kind of a shock to me to see
them
talking about my i mean these are
religious scholars talking about my
biblical series um but i think people
are just
people don't a lot of people didn't
understand
and i could see it in my react with the
way people were
reacting to your biblical studies the
biblical uh interpretations people
didn't understand how is it that he
we can barely get 100 people in our
church and jordan has
a million people listening to him kind
of struggle to
to get through these passages and do it
in a very improvisational kind of uh
existential way um and uh and to me it's
funny because i mean i think i
i have i have a deep affection for
your the way that you approach thing and
i and obviously we connect together in
the way we think and so
to me it was like this is what you guys
should have been doing for a while
is trying to understand how it is that
this stuff is talking about reality
and not just a bunch of arbitrary things
that you need to believe or that you
need to kind of attend to
and and because these stories they
really are
telling us about the structure of being
and so i think that that's
the way that you approached it and and
that's why people are resonating to what
you're saying because
they're like finally someone can can
can help us make sense of these stories
that we're somehow strangely attracted
to or
frustrated by or disgusted by or
whatever it is but there's this push and
pull with these stories
um and so so i think that i've seen a
lot of christians listen to your
biblical talks and of course sometimes
you say things and they're like okay
that's way off the rails
and then other times you say things and
they can't believe the insight that
you're able to
to pierce and so so i i'm not not all
surprised that catholic scholars would
would kind of look at what you were
doing
and we all hope that you're going to do
more of that for sure
yes well i would like to i'm thinking
about trying to attempt a book on exodus
and lecture two
lectures as well although i wouldn't say
that i'm in any shape to do that yet
um i'm but it's a dream let's say
i mean i'm pretty much completely
non-functional for the first
three or four hours of the day i get up
and i can barely stand up
and i go have a sauna for an hour and
often sleep during that
period of time and then at the same time
i cook breakfast uh i use an air cooker
and then i go walk for
anywhere between seven and ten miles and
even though i can
by the time i get out of the house i'm
dizzy as as can be
and it's difficult to stand up but after
about a mile or two i get
my legs under me to some degree and then
by two o'clock
i'm kind of functional and although
extremely anxious and then
um i'm able to do a little bit of work
and often to sit down at four o'clock my
mind seems sharp enough
although my memory isn't good i can't
bring things to mind like i used to
which is quite distressing and i have
very little emotional resilience and
i'm worried for that reason about the
release of this book i mean i
i just did a times interview london
times interview that was really
yeah we followed that i'd say it's that
frustrating it's it's
it's i mean it's funny because this you
know again it was like the same
stories are playing out again this
person goes after you
and then it just turns against that
person and and it's just
she's exposed for for the fraud that she
was being and during that interview and
so
you know i think in the it's so strange
that it keeps happening over and over i
mean i really decided not to do
mainstream
interviews now for a good while because
i've
it seems to me that i've gone to the
well of public sympathy so to speak
enough times and that if this happens to
me two or three more times let's say
people are going to
rightly say you know how many times does
it take for peterson to learn
and so i don't want that to happen i
mean i've been
you know i feel an obligation to my
publishers obviously to talk about the
book
although that interview had virtually
nothing to do with the book we hoped
that
i would be able to discuss my health
issues with someone
who would treat them squarely and then i
could ignore them
from then on in but um
uh that isn't what happened um
well it's been it's a sign of the
politicized discourse like
you you it's a sign of the breakdown
that we're going through
that we see this capacity to have so
entrenched aside that people are
can't doesn't doesn't matter what they
do it doesn't matter what they say
they don't feel like they're responsible
because in a way you're the enemy
and you know and it's not just you it's
other other it's between different
groups but
if you're the enemy then everything is
justified
and so well i think a huge part of this
is is driven by the desire to have an
enemy
yeah you know there's it's
it's very difficult to feel it's an easy
route to self-righteousness to have an
enemy
exactly and yeah and it's a great place
to put all evil
yeah and because you attract so much
attention you're an easy
you're definitely an easy target well
that's the theory
seems not to turn out that way yeah but
it's also was the timing
you know the way when you kind of came
up in the public
uh sphere there was a massive shift
happening in culture
and i think that's one of the things you
could feel and that was happening around
us
and to some extent you know donald trump
had something to do with that as well
in the sense that it was this malaise
that was there and this kind of
this jostling and this this uh and this
is what led to all that kind of
discourse and so
i think that you you were identified you
became identified almost
mythologically i guess as as a character
and and people you know have treat you
that way and they act with you that way
in many respects yes it becomes very
difficult to
to understand very difficult for me to
understand what character i
am
you know so much has changed in my life
over the last five years i'm i've been
on leave from the university so that's
very destabilizing
i don't have my clinical practice
anymore and so i was you know seeing 20
people a week
so that's a huge transformation in my
life my my house has been completely
renovated it was renovated well my wife
was ill
and so we didn't uh well it the
renovation went on in our absence and
so i'm a foreigner in my own house which
is
which is although i'm starting to become
accustomed to it and there's some things
i like about the new house but
i don't feel at home in it i wouldn't
say and i've only been here for two
months in the last three years
because i was on the road and then
well all this
and so that and everything that's
happened has been very disruptive for my
family
and of course tammy got so unbelievably
sick and and with something that was
supposed to be fatal and recovered
more or less miraculously um
and then i've been so unbelievably ill
or still am and
i i have just i just don't know where to
put any of this
i i can't think about the past at all
because
so much of it is incomprehensible
especially
over the last five years i can't think
about the present because i'm in so much
pain and i can't think about the future
because i don't know what i'm going to
do and i have no idea how long this pain
is going to last
it's been i've been in pain
really severe pain for two years now and
yeah
um and that's
it's it's a strange thing because in
this book one of the chapters
the last chapter is called be grateful
in spite of your suffering
you know and um i went every
through every sentence in that chapter a
very large number of times because
much of the time while i was rewriting
it particularly i was in
a lot of pain and um
like it's it's it's it's a pain
level that's hard to
fathom in some sense because i would say
every single day i have now
is worse than any day i ever had in my
life before i got ill
so and then i know very well that
adding bitterness to your
malaise is a very bad idea you know it
doesn't help
but that that i can certainly see the
attraction in that i feel like shaking
my fist at the sky
and complaining bitterly and
but it it doesn't help but but there
doesn't seem to be any relief either
and so that's it's so it's so perverse
it's shaken my faith
i suppose i
i'm in this perverse position where
my work has in principle helped so many
people
and yet i don't seem to be able to dig
myself out of my
current circumstances so
well or even to make sense of them yeah
i think that i think that the role that
you've
you played is a is a kind of a
transition
role and that transition
manifests itself to you as a
as a trying to have your feet on two
sides of
rifting of an eye two islands that are
floating away from each other
and you you you're trying to hold on
you're trying to kind of help people
focus on the middle and help people
avoid radicalization and avoid falling
into camps in a manner that will
lead to god knows what
and so i think that
i think that that's the role that you
played and it's
and it's been like i've seen for example
people transition through your work
transition from worlds moving
worlds that's really what i've seen
happen it's more than just changing
the way changing your opinion or
changing your mind about something it
really is about changing the world you
inhabit
and so that's a that's a crazy
that's a crazy role to play and
especially because like i said you
you have your foot it's like you kind of
have your
one foot or one eye let's say looking
towards
i would call religion or looking towards
christianity
or something like that and then you have
another eye which is
still very much immersed in a kind of
secular
humanism and you have one leg that is
you know you understand people that are
more left-leaning you understand people
that are more right-leaning
you have this capacity to kind of
understand everybody but you're
yeah it's it's uh that means that you
make enemies on
on all sides too well you know the
overwhelming response that i've got
publicly has been i would say
traumatically
positive yeah and you wouldn't think
that that would be possible really but
i find it that way i mean partly it's
overwhelming to have people
constantly tell me in person
their responses to what i've been doing
it's very emotional
and i get caught up in that quite
quickly
and of course on youtube and the social
media platforms
youtube particularly the bulk of the
comments
about me are very very positive
it's 99 to 1 often in terms of likes and
dislikes it's
yeah and and it's too much
well i don't know how i don't know how
to i don't know how to
i don't know what category to put it in
i don't know how to conceptualize it
i mean part of part of me the practical
part
of course says well i just happened to
adopt a new technology at a time when it
started to boom
and filled a kind of niche that was
empty in that technology at that time
but
in some sense that that doesn't really
cut it you know
because it doesn't have anything to do
with the content then i think well i
have been dealing with these
well borderline religious issues well
certainly not just borderline
there's lots of religious people who
seem to think that i'm dealing with
religious issues
and well and that's really what i wanted
to talk to you about tonight
so this book i mentioned earlier
to talked about disagreements with my
conceptualization of christ let's say
and which i and i'm not sure what that
conceptualization is by the way
exactly it's a mystery to me um but
but i can say some some concrete things
about it i mean
i certainly i i understand and
appreciate
the symbolic significance of the ideal
human being
and that finds its embodiment and i took
these ideas in large part from jung
and eric neumann that that
christ is a represent christ is at least
a representation of
the ideal man whatever that is and
and we we all interestingly enough we
all seem to have an ideal
and we and that i or that ideal has us
right and that's where it's very
interesting to consider
the role of conscience because
your conscience will call you out on
your behavior
and so it seems to function as something
that's somewhat independent
or at least is something that you can't
fully voluntarily control because if you
could voluntarily control it
then you just tell the pesky little
bastard to go away
or to pat you on the back continually
because there must be few things in life
more pleasurable than being a fully
committed narcissist
to really believe that everything that
you do is right and that you're a good
person
and i suppose if you could wave a magic
wand and rearrange your mind so that it
was constantly telling you that
you do it but you don't seem to be able
to do that in relationship to your
conscience
it trips you up and so and so
it tells you when you're not living up
to your own ideal
and that means that you have an ideal
and you don't even know what the hell it
is but you certainly know when you
transgress against it
and i know that there's a strong line of
christian thinking that's identified
the conscience with divinity sometimes
with christ
inside sometimes with the holy spirit
and those are very interesting
conceptualizations but you can think of
them psychologically and
you can even think about them
biologically you know to some degree
because we're so
social if we
don't manifest an appropriate moral
reciprocity
we're going to become alienated from our
fellows and we won't survive
and we'll suffer and die and we won't we
certainly won't
find a partner and and have children
successfully and so
to some degree the conscience can be
viewed as the voice of
reciprocal society within and that's a
perfectly reasonable biological
explanation
but but the thing is is the deeper you
go into biology the more it shades into
something that appears to be religious
because you start
analyzing the fundamental structure of
the psyche itself
and and it becomes something
well it becomes something with a pow
with
with a with a with with a power that
transcends your ability to resist it
so okay so you can think about christ
from a psychological perspective and
the crit the critic my critic
this particular critic that i've been
reading
said well that that doesn't
differentiate christ much from a whole
sequence of dying and resurrecting
mythological gods and of course people
have made that
claim in comparative religion joseph
campbell
did that and jung to a lesser degree i
would say but campbell did that
but the difference and c.s lewis pointed
this out as well the difference between
those mythological gods and christ was
that
there's a there's a representation of
there's a historical representation of
his of of his existence as well
now you can debate whether or not that's
genuine
you can debate about whether or not he
actually lived and whether there's
credible objective evidence for that but
it doesn't matter in some sense because
this well it does but
there's a sense in which it doesn't
matter because there's still a
historical story and so what you have in
the figure of christ is
an actual person who actually lived plus
a myth and in some sense christ is the
union of those two things
the problem is is i probably believe
that but i don't know
i don't i'm amazed at my own belief and
i don't understand it
like because i've seen
sometimes the objective
world and the narrative world
touch know that's union synchronicity
and i've seen that many times in my own
life
and so in some sense i believe it's
undeniable you know
we have a narrative sense of the world
for me that's been the world of morality
that's the world that tells us how to
act
it's real like we treat it like it's
real it's not the objective world
but the narrative and the objective
world touch and the ultimate example of
that in principle is supposed to be
christ
but i don't know what to and that seems
to me oddly plausible
yeah but i still don't know what to make
of it it's too
hit partly because it's too terrifying a
reality to
fully believe i don't even know what
would happen to you if you fully
believed it
if you believed in the story of christ
or if you believe that
history and and let's say the narrative
make meat let's both i think i think you
because when you believe that you buy
both those stories you believe that the
narrative and the objective can actually
touch
yeah i mean we saw that you and i i mean
this is a trivial example but
we had a when we were discussing we had
a sequence of discussions around
frog symbolism
four years ago yeah that was very
bizarre to say the least
you know and that was a trivial example
relatively trivial example of the
narrative world in the objective world
coming together
didn't feel that trivial at the time
well the way the way that i like to deal
with this is that
one of the things it it's already there
in your thought
it's already there in the way that you
talk about reality which is that
one of the constitutive aspects of how
reality unfolds
and how it appears to us is something
like attention
right it's something there's a hierarchy
of of manifestation because everything
that hap
that appears to us in the world has a an
infinite amount of details right it has
an indefinite amount of
ways that you could describe it that you
could angle that
by which you could analyze it and so
nonetheless the world appears to us
through
these hierarchies of meaning right i
always kind of use the example of a cup
or a chair
like a chair is is of just a multitude
of things it's a multitude of parts how
is it that we can say that it's one
thing
there's a there's a capacity we have to
attend and this capacity we have to
attend
is something like a co-creation of the
world
and so the world actually exists a chair
is a good example
because you know you can try to define
it objectively but you end up with bean
bags and stumps and
exactly and they don't have anything in
common well they're both made of matter
you know for whatever that's worth it's
pretty pretty trivial level of
commonality but you can sit on them
yeah and that's what you have there's a
mode of being which they find well and
that's
so strange so many of our object
perceptions are
projected modes of being and so even the
objective world is
inelectably contaminated with its
utility and
then or therefore with morality exactly
and so i think that that's the key
the key is that once you understand that
the world manifests itself through
attention and that consciousness has a
place to play in actually the way
in which the world reveals itself and so
you can you can try to posit a world
outside of that first person perspective
but it's
it's good it's it's a deluded uh
activity well it's also
it's very very difficult because you
don't you
you don't know what to make of something
like time
because time has an inerratically
subjective element
and duration which is different than
time i mean time is
kind of like the average rate at which
things change but duration is something
like the felt sense of that time
and if you take away this objectivity it
isn't obvious what to do with time and i
think physicists stumble over this all
the time
so to speak so and this is something
that
this this intermingling of value and
fact was something that i never thought
i never thought i made much traction
with with harris with sam harris
he he didn't seem to me to be willing to
admit
how saturated the world of fact is
inevitably with value and i actually
think he's denying the science at that
point because
for everything i know about perceptual
psychology
there's a great book called uh um
vision as a oh god now i can't remember
the name of the books that's
memory trouble i'll remember it no
worries
the idea is that if that is true
then there are certain things which come
out of that there are certain necessary
uh things down the road from that that
insight
which is that attention plays a part in
the way the world lays itself out
um and that one of them and one of them
is that the stuff
that the world is made of is partly
something like attention something like
consciousness and that has a pattern
and that pattern is the same pattern as
stories
it just it just it doesn't lay itself
out exactly the same but
things exist with a pattern which is
similar to stories
they have identities they have centers
they have margins
they have exceptions and that's how
stories lay themselves out
like so a story happens in time how an
identity
let's say uh is
broken down and then reconstructed you
could say that that's basically the
story of
every story how something breaks down
and is reconstructed
and so that is a way for us to perceive
uh
the identity of things and so if the
world
is made of this then it's actually
it's actually our world our secular
world which is a strange
aberration on how reality
used to exist for every culture and
every time from the beginning of time
which is to take that for granted
to take for granted that something that
they didn't call it consciousness but
intelligence
and attention are part of how the world
lays itself out
and it lays itself out in modes of being
and
one of the things that comes out of it
is not only that but
like you said it's not only that
you have ideas but it's that ideas have
you or that it's not only that you
engage in modes of being it's that modes
of being
have you and that recognition
means that the first level of
the first level of attention to that
looks something like worship it looks
like
celebration it looks like uh
it it's like uh the the thing which
makes
the let's say the national hockey league
so successful
has more to do with celebration than
just a bunch of guys
on skates on a piece of ice you know
throwing a puck around
there's a celebration of the purpose of
that thing and it manifests itself
through a bunch of stuff which one is
like a trophy that stands in the middle
on the top of a bunch of
on a stand and everybody looks at it and
kisses it and and
and so there's this this veneration yeah
and there's mascots
the hockey league example is very
interesting because it's a
it's a it's a social game and
you know all the players
are they're attempting to aim right
right so
there's a symbolic element to that sin
is misplaced aim
and so you hit the you hit the small
space in the net
blocked though it may be by your enemies
and
everyone celebrates that and you do that
in cooperation with other people and
in competition with other people and if
you do it properly not only are you a
brilliant player from a technical
perspective but you're also a great
sport and so there's an ethic there and
a morality and
and this is why people are so upset when
hockey players or any other pro
athlete does something immoral in their
personal life is because it violates the
the ethic that that's being celebrated
as a consequence of this great game yeah
and
right so you can see that that the
striving for an ideal mode of being the
religious striving for an ideal mode of
being is
central to what it is that makes hockey
um
addictive that's right yeah necessarily
and and so god i saw that pro wrestling
there's a great documentary uh bret hart
called hitman hearts one of the best
documentaries i've ever seen
and it portrays pro wrestling as a
stark religious battle between the
forces of good and evil and bret hart
who at one point was the most famous
canadian in the world
was overwhelmed by his the archetypal
force of his
representation as the good guy it's a
great documentary hitman heart
and and it shows you how you know pro
wrestling is
is it's not the world's most
intellectual activity
to say the least and people can easily
be dismissive of it but
one of the things i loved about the
documentary was that it attempted to
understand from within what was
compelling about what was being
portrayed and it was a religious drama
it just
was shocking and brilliant and so
so that is that is actually there is a
there's an objective
part of that that there's an objective
way in which these patterns kind of come
together and manifest let's say higher
and higher
versions of this drama uh and so the
sports drama
has a certain level but it's it's
limited to a certain extent
because it still happens as a
confrontation let's say between
two irreducible sides and so what
happens in something like the story of
christ is that
that gets taken into one person
and so all the opposites become
the king and the the the the criminal
the you know the highest even in the
image of the cross you have this image
sandy as christ is being crucified
they're putting a sign above his head
saying that he's the king
as christ is being beaten they're giving
to him a crown
and so christ joins together all the
opposites
and so in his in his story
you see if you if you're attentive to
these patterns you see
the highest form of this pattern being
played out
and one of the aspects that has to be
there for it to be
the most revealed or highest form is
that it also has to include
the world of manifestation i mean it
can't just be a story
it has to be connected to the world so
that's why christians
insist on the the the fact that jesus is
not just a story
that he's an incarnated man that he was
incarnated
but i don't believe their insistence i
don't believe
well this is this is because i don't
it isn't obvious to me and i think
maybe i derived this criticism from
nietzsche but
i mean people have asked me whether or
not i believe in god and
i've answered in various ways no but i'm
afraid he probably exists
that's that's one answer um yeah no
but i'm terrified he might exist that
that would be truthful answer
to some degree or that i act as if god
exists
which i think is i'd do my best to do
that but then
there's a real stumbling block there
because
there's no limit to what would happen if
you acted like god existed
yeah you know what i mean because i
believe that
that acting that out fully
i mean maybe it's not reasonable to say
to believers
you aren't sufficiently transformed for
me to believe that you believe in god
or that you believe the story that
you're telling me you're not you're not
a sufficient
you're not the way you live is a
sufficient testament to the truth
and people would certainly say that
let's say about the catholic church or
at least the way that it's been
portrayed is that
with all the sexual corruption for
example it's like really really
you believe that the son of god that
jesus christ was the son of
god and yet you act that way and i'm
supposed to buy your belief
and and it seems to me that the church
is actually
quite um guilty on that account
because the attempts to clean up the
mess
have been rather half-hearted in my
estimation
and so i don't think people people don't
manif
christians don't manifest this and i'm
including myself i suppose in that
description
perhaps um don't manifest
the transformation of attitude that
would
enable that enables the outside observer
to easily
conclude that they believe yeah now the
way
the way to deal with that or the way to
to understand that is that
it they do but they do in a hierarchy
there's a there's a hierarchy of
manifestation of the transformation that
god offers the world and we kind of live
in that hierarchy and those
above us hold us together you would say
and so in the church there's a testimony
of the saints
there's there are stories there are
hundreds and hundreds of stories of
people
who live that out in their particular
context
to the limit of what it's possible to
live it and even today there are
there are saints living saints who for
example like in the orthodox tradition
we have this
idea of what they call it the gift of
tears or the joyful sorrow
of of people who live in prayer
with weeping constant weeping uh and
it's this kind of
strange mix of joy and uh and sadness
which they
which kind of overwhelm them and they
live in that joy and sadness non-stop
and they pray
you know without end and so that exists
but then we
in this that's one of the reasons why
that's kind of one of the reasons why
when i talk about this idea of attention
like it manifests itself in the
in the church as well is that
you often say and i understand it when
you say something like
you know i act as if god exists or you
know i'm afraid to say that god exists
uh and i think it's because you you
think
or you tend to think that the moral
weight
like of that is so strong that you would
we would crumble under it that you would
just be crushed under it
and and i think that and i think that
that's
i think that i i understand that
but
the first thing that to act as if god
exists let's say it this way
to act as as if god exists the first
thing that it asks of you is not
a moral action the first thing that it
asks
asks of you is attention
that's why to act as if god exists is
first of all to worship like that's and
i know people are going to hear this
well then i have then i have a
terrible problem with that too at the
moment because i'm in so much pain
like one of the things that one of these
theologians
discussed the idea of and sorry i want
you to let you get back to your point
but he discussed the idea of
the yoke of christ being light and that
there is joy in it
and um and there's a paradox there
obviously because
it's it's also a take up your cross and
follow me sort of thing
but um
the fact that i've been living in
constant pain makes the
idea of joy seem um
cruel i would say and so
and i have no idea how to reconcile
myself to that i mean i've reconciled
myself to that
by staying alive despite it you know
um although
by staying alive despite it but there's
very little worship and it doesn't mean
i'm not
appreciative of what i have i'm i'm not
only am i appreciative of what i have
i do everything i can to remind myself
of it all the time and so does my wife i
mean she's changed quite a bit as a
consequence of her
struggle with cancer you know has become
much more overtly religious i would say
and
you know we say grace before our meal
in the evening and it's very serious
enterprise and
it always centers around gratitude you
know for
well for for the ridiculous
volume of blessings that have been
showered down
upon us at a volume that's really
quite incomprehensible but
despite that um well let
despite that i'm struggling with this
because i don't know how to reconcile
myself
to the to the fact of constant pain
yeah and i don't i feel that it's unjust
which is halfway to being resentful
which is not a good outcome
no i i i agree and i can't speak
like i can't i don't know how to speak
to that because i don't necessarily
don't have that experience
you know i don't i i don't have that i
don't live with constant pain and so i
don't know
what that would do to me probably
probably one of the reasons why
it might ruin me you know and so
um it's very difficult to answer that i
think that
the answer like the answer has been the
cross like that's been the answer it's
an ease maybe it may be easy for me to
just say it that way uh but that's
always been the
answer of of christianity which is that
that god went to to the cross and that
god went
down into death and and plunged down
into death and there
that there are mysteries hidden and
there maybe they're very well hidden but
there are mysteries hidden in that
than that depth um
but uh it's not i don't think it's my
job to uh
to to moralize to you at this point at
this particular moment
so we talked about the narrative and the
object of touching and so i wanted to
touch on that again is that
like i i i understand cs lewis's
argument and you know i'm even inclined
from time to time to think well i've got
the choice between believing two
impossible things
i can either believe that in the world
is constituted so that god took on flesh
and was crucified and
and and died and rose three days later
or i can believe
that human beings invented this
unbelievably preposterous story that
stretched into every
atom of of culture
and it isn't obvious to me that
the second hypothesis is any easier to
believe than the first because the more
you investigate
the the manifestations of the story of
christ the more insanely complicated and
far-reaching it becomes so
i read ion for example and for all of
those who are listening if you want to
read a book that will completely make
you insane
then you could read jung's eye on and
it's a study of
christian symbolism in astrology which
doesn't sound particularly dangerous but
or or or or even particularly necessary
to read i suppose but
young describes the the juxtaposition of
astrological and
christian symbolism and it's a brilliant
book and it's terrifying because he
he he outlines the concordance between
the levels of symbolism
over several thousand years and it's
obvious
when you read the book that no one
plotted this it's not a conspiracy
whatever is going on to make that
concordance occur isn't something that
we understand and it seems to be best
understood as one of these situations
where
the narrative and the objective touch
the saturation of christianity with fish
symbolism
young associates with astrological
movement of
of uh into the house of pisces
and and so he he describes how a
drama so ancient people saw a drama
played out in the sky and that was a
projection of their imagination
and that projection contained symbols
that were associated with the emergence
of christianity
and so you you can see in that the the
the alternative explanation is that
there's this
there's this unfolding of a symbolic
landscape over centuries or millennia
that's part of human biological and
cultural evolution
but that that starts to touch on the
religious
anyways when you when you describe it in
those terms
like it's it's it's the operation of a
of a cognitive
of a natural cognitive process let's say
natural slash cognitive process that
supersedes any one individual or any one
culture
and so i've never seen a critique of ion
you know i think people read that book
and they think
oh it's like john allegro's uh
the sacred the mushroom and the sacred
cross do you know of that book i
believe that's the title that's another
book you read and you think
well i have no idea what it's a study of
mushroom symbolism in christianity and
it's another book that
you know it it claims that christianity
was heavily influenced
by psilocybin use and it was published
in the 1960s it's an amazing book
but it's another book you read and you
think i have no idea what to do with
that i have no
place to put that book so
but ion is really like that and well one
of the things that for example
you know we talked about just before the
idea that
um you know the idea of christ being a
dying and resurrecting god and
you know that's really actually not the
case if you
actually just look at the story of
christ and not just the story in
scripture but
let's say the whole story as it kind of
developed in tradition and kind of
melded together in the ancient world you
had this idea of gods that went down
into the underworld
you know either that went down for some
reason to visit or went down to save
somebody even or
you know or or died and then and then
rose again but
that's actually not the story of christ
because
if you if you understand the full
tradition of the christian story we
think that
christ died went into hades
and then destroyed death and he pulls
everybody out of death
and then that's it like what other story
are you going to tell after that story
you have a story of someone who dies
goes into death and then take and then
destroys death and then
that's it like that that's the thing
with christ's story that every story
every aspect of his story reaches the
limit of storytelling
and it's it's impossible beyond it right
that's right that's right well even from
a psychological perspective that's
correct
and that in itself is a kind of miracle
and so you're stuck in some sense
constantly having to choose between
miracles it's like okay
it's a it's a figment of the human
imagination fine but it's the limit
figment
in multiple ways how did that happen and
also
but as soon as you start to start to
think that the world is made
of attention the idea of just a figment
of somebody's imagination
especially just a figment of someone's
imagination which is
happens like you said over thousands of
years within communities of thousands of
people
it just becomes a ridiculous statement
it doesn't it doesn't mean anything
it's like yeah it only means something
if you assume that and jung pointed this
out it only means something
it only
to say it's a figment of imagination and
have that
brush it aside means that you think that
imagination
is nothing and you pointed out
constantly that
you should not attribute nothing to the
psyche
it's what you depend upon it's it's the
ground of your existence
it's it's it's not nothing
it's the thing you that you take for
granted more than anything else
so any anything that you can or
recognize as a story
will definitely be manifesting patterns
that
you can recognize and so they can't just
be brushed aside
from this from the most insane
conspiracy theory
to the the most you know like childish
fairy tale
anything that manifests itself as a as a
pattern of story that you can recognize
is has a certain level of value
has a an enough level that if you pay
attention to it
you actually can gather some some some
nuggets of uh
of how the world works and how the world
lays itself out
uh you know and that's why like if i do
symbolic interpretations i can do it for
scripture but i can also do it
for some marvel movie or some video game
or whatever it is because
that's just the for you to even
recognize something as having being
it's already part of that world it's
already manifesting these patterns
this critic
said that the mere psychologization of
christ
was insufficient because and you made
the same case
in some sense that it doesn't make sense
unless the narrative and the
objective world truly touch and i think
you could debate that because i think
that
there's some utility there could argue
to be
be some utility in a secular version of
the hero myth
you know that the best way to cope with
existence is to
for to tell the truth and to face what
you don't know
forthrightly and that will enable you to
orient yourself
within our finite and bounded existence
that ends with our death
more properly more accurately
more advisedly than any other route
i've seen people from orthodox priests
to
you know the more the most protestant
protestant you can imagine
recognize in the way that you represent
reality something that has value
something that has value because
you're you are manifesting that that
pattern like what you're saying is
is true uh but i think that
i think that if we if we if we take
seriously
this the prop the relationship between
attention
psyche and the way the world reveals
itself to us
then it scales up it scales up after
that
it it jumps up a level and
uh it also scales up in terms of because
one of the things that
one of the things that that you talk
about like looking up to the star and
and looking up to the highest thing you
can look at and then aiming
towards that you know once again
one of the things that that does for is
that
the first thing you do is actually where
it's a form it's a tension that people
won't like the word worship it's a form
of reverence a
form of veneration you submit yourself
to that aim
so it's not just that you see the aim
and that you aim for it
you actually have to submit yourself to
that which is
to what you're aiming and so that
sacrifice to it
exactly and you have to sacrifice to it
so that's why
let's say the religious version of this
has to move towards the highest
possible aim and also one that we can do
together
because like the lower aims like you
could call them something like lower
gods let's say or angels or whatever you
want to call them
like these lower aims they have value
but they're all
fragmented but for this to stack up we
need to be able to look towards the same
image we need to look towards the same
aim and that will bind us together
and so we don't we don't all then we
don't also end up being
just kind of individuals who have the
weight of the world on our shoulders
but we're a communion of saints we're
communion of
people who are submitted to aiming
towards
worshipping the same
point yeah and i believe that that's
necessary and and i've i've had some
profound experiences which i can't
really relate here that
of of the necessity for that community
is that this
whatever our fundamental moral load is
immense though it is um crushing
though it is even um requires
the participation of others so even if
you were the perfect you
you would need other people to be along
with you it's a collective enterprise
even though it's an individualistic
even though it requires the perfection
it requires
as much perfection as is possible at the
individual level
that's not enough there has to be that
communal element as well you need help
we all need help to aim as ha the
highest aim requires communal endeavor
yeah and it's also because it actually
is the way that everything works you
know it's like the chair aiming to be a
chair
is a is a constitutive of parts which
are
joined together towards a a same goal
and therefore hold together as a being
and manifest the chairness of the chair
and that's the same with you you have
all these thoughts right you have all
these
feelings all these these contradicting
things inside you
and you need by aiming up towards
you know the the i mean i believe that
the image of christ let's say by aiming
towards the image of christ
you constitute your being into that
being that's able to
attend to sacrifice to love and then
that scales up with people
i agree well i think you are i mean this
is another something else i tried to
point out to sam
um you are you're aiming you're either
aiming at christ or something lesser
yeah or if things get really out of hand
you're aiming at something opposite
and you don't want to be doing that but
and this is a matter of definition in
some sense and
it's actually not impossible to
understand is that
you aim at something better generally
speaking i mean maybe you're out to
cause pain but forget about that
you you aim at something better you
wouldn't do it unless it was better in
fact
it virtually defines better like
the whole idea of better is predicated
on the idea that there's an aim that's
beyond you
and then the highest of those aims is
the amalgamate the highest aim is the
amalgam a
amalgamation of all higher aims and
that's a perfect mode of being
and and that by definite that's a
psychological perspective again that by
definition is christ
and then but then there seems to be
something too convenient about cs
lewis's insistence
that that also had to manifest itself
concretely in reality at one point in
history
and i'm not like i
i don't understand why i should believe
that
and i don't i tend not to believe things
without a why there's always a why
and yeah and i there's there's a hurdle
there that i
that that well that i waver on
constantly because
i well i already said that you're when
you think these things through
at least my experience has been if you
think them through sufficiently you end
up with
the choice between impossible
alternatives and so yeah
but it has to do one of the ways to see
it maybe is
is it has to do with the recognizing of
the goodness of the world or the
goodness of creation
that that the world is capable
of manifesting these patterns right so
if you want to understand for example
the big conflict between the early
gnostics and the christians that's what
it was
all about because the gnostics basically
wanted a disincarnated christ they were
saying
you know and they viewed the world as
utterly fallen as having no value
having to be escaped having to be fled
in every way
whereas christianity posits that
it's a non-dual it's a non-dual
proposition it's saying
it's it all comes together that's the
that's the promise it all comes together
and so
it has to come down right and so it has
to come down
at every level and not only does have to
come down into the person of christ
who's incarnated but that person
has to go down down into death to the
very bottom of the world
you know to the belly of the leviathan
and then
come back up and so the whole world is
declared as once again declared as
ha being capable of participating in
this good
and so and so you could say well maybe
maybe it wasn't that one maybe it wasn't
you know it's like why would it be that
particular
particular place where it happened but
it had to be that's some
place that's the story i mean that's
where that there is no
other story like that story that we have
and
and so once you recognize that this is
part of
the declaration that the world does
embody these patterns
that it leads to this it leads to the
the this this story of of a man who
embodied them
absolutely and is bringing us in him
to also embody them in a way that will
transform us
you know like the the ultimate goal of
of orthodox
vision of christianity is is theosis
it's to become
god to become god through to
transformation and participation in god
so that's the final goal of everything
is to become
participant in the divine and how do you
how do you distinguish that from
catholicism
no i i mean in terms of that i think
that it's a difference of emphasis i
think
for sure the orthodox emphasized theosis
more than the
than the catholics the catholics are
kind of iffy about theosis
in terms of it's there in some of the
thinkers but it i would say it's
probably not official
catholic doctrine but i think without
theosis you're missing
the point of the whole thing or you're
missing the point of
of everything like why why do things
exist
right like why do things exist and so i
think that
the idea that they exist to participate
fully in
their most perfect form like that's what
they're called to
to to part to to do you know and it ends
up being a
declaration of the ultimate possibility
for goodness in the world
i think that that's yeah
well it
it seems it seemed to me i've observed
let's say that
it's possible to
it isn't obvious to me that anyone wants
to leave live a meaningless existence
i don't think you can live a meaningless
existence without becoming corrupted
because the pain of existence will
corrupt you without
a saving meaning
and it also seems to me that you can
sell the story that meaning is to be
found in responsibility
when i've tried to sell that story to
myself i seem to buy it and
when i've tried to communicate it with
other people it renders them silent
large crowds of people silent and that's
strange because
i i'm not sure why that is it's perhaps
because the connection between
responsibility and meaning had never
been made
for in in that explicitly somehow
because meaning gets contaminated with
happiness or
something like that but it's to be found
in responsibility and then you could say
well there isn't any
any responsibility that's more
compelling than
trying to aid things in the
manifestation
of their divine form that should be an
adventure that could be
sold and i don't know why the church
can't do it
i don't understand that and
because it seems to me that that's
something that i've done at least in
part
and that accounts for the strange
popularity of the biblical
lectures in particular yeah and
but i've also and i i do believe that i
do believe that that
the right striving is to attempt with
all your heart to
encourage things to develop along that
towards that divine
goal like what else would you possibly
do once you think that through
it's like you're always aiming at
something that's
better or you wouldn't be aiming you're
always moving towards something that's
better or you wouldn't be moving so
then why wouldn't you move towards the
greatest good
yeah well it's because it's terrifying i
suppose in part
but then as you know i've tried to put
that into practice in my life and
it's tearing me into pieces yeah
i don't know though if if one of the
reasons
it's because you're also alone
and i you know i because you
i mean at least to my understanding
you're not in a in a in a community
um well it's hard to say i mean it's
hard to say because fans aren't
certainly haven't last well they've been
a community
i mean yeah one of the things that has
held me together certainly is
the commitment that i feel to
to the people who've been so positive
towards me
and my family i do feel that as a
community
i understand what you mean why the hell
not go to church
you know i know he wasn't gonna come
right out and say it jordan
yeah i know you're not that blunt about
it
but it's not just you know it's not just
about going to church i one time i
i told you something and and i don't
know if i could drive if i was able to
drive it through
there there's something about being in a
hierarchy
that is that because there's an aspect
of being in a hierarchy that you talk
about which is this kind of striving
to to kind of be the best within that
hierarchy but there's an aspect of being
in a hierarchy
which is that the hierarchy covers you
oh definitely there's no doubt about
that
yeah and so there's something about
that's why the lowest
member the lowest status members of a
chimp group will
still fight off interlopers yeah and so
there's
there's a value in being in a community
and a
and a hierarchy where you like i go to
confession right
i go to confession i go to my priest and
i confess my sins
and and i give that to him
he actually takes responsibility for
for an aspect of listening to my sins
and and kind of participating in my
salvation and he
and so the weight ends up being
distributed across the community
it's not so you don't actually just bear
it on your
on yourself and it's not just even and
it's not just a living community it's a
it's not just those that are live in the
in the hierarchy but those that are
that have left their story all the
saints are part of this hierarchy that
you
engage in that you participate in and
that you see as
consolation as examples as you know as
examples of people who have lived
through difficult things that you can
kind of
uh that you can shoulder up against you
know and so
that's one of the reasons why i i kind
of insist with at least for the people
that watch my videos is
is when i say go to church it's not just
because i
trying to moralize you into doing
something it's because
it's a it's actually a participation in
how the best
vision of reality works
i've got no objection to any of that
but i've seen you i've seen you
objection i'm probably one of the only
people
in the world that has actually seen you
in church and seen
you yeah that's worm and squirm in
church
why
see the other thing i was reading again
i was reading this book and it's been
mostly a jumping off place for me to
think it's like
there's also something because i'm not
inside the church
so to speak it's hard to say what the
utility of that is
the utility of being inside the church
of being outside it oh being
because i'm an outsider talking about
religious matters
yeah but i think that i think that i
think that it has played
a great role like i i've often said
something that
i've often said that you're something
like king cyrus if you know the story of
king cyrus
in scripture king cyrus was a persian
king
who told the jews to go back to israel
and build their temple
so he wasn't jewish like he was he
wasn't an israelite he wouldn't believe
in the god of the israelites but he was
like hey
you know that temple of yours looks
pretty nice why don't you just go back
there and
and rebuild your own own thing and so
that's
definitely an effect that i've seen you
have you know the number of people that
have
become christian because of you is
hilarious sorry it's not hilarious but
it's just kind of it's just kind of this
strange thing because you you you kind
of stand outside and you look at you're
looking at the door and you're looking
at the church and you're saying
hey this isn't not so bad you know look
at this what is what is going on here
like what is this
about and and then because of that oh
it's also do you think you've got
something
better you know i was talking to a
friend of mine the other day when we
were walking
because as i said i walk about 10 miles
a day right now
try to keep myself under control
and you know he he was raised a
communist in poland
and and then an atheist and
he was complaining i think i think this
is what he told me that he was
complaining to his parents at one point
about a religious wedding that they were
going to despite not believing
and he said as he got older he realized
he had nothing to replace that with
it's like okay throw it out fine okay
now where are you
well you're just as bad off as you were
before but you also don't have that
beautiful thing
yeah it's like what would happen if we
dispensed with christmas
well if it's not it's a good thing
or we could say we could make it
entirely secular but then it would just
disappear
but you know that's not what's going to
happen because religion is inevitable
and we're seeing it coming back in very
strange ways
it's going to be a weird woke uh
identitarian religion which is
which is going to come back that's why
primitive you know
it did part of it's part of it's going
to be privately doesn't matter
can you believe that yeah so it's a it's
a scary thing like that's what you could
say that that's one of the
failures of the new atheists is that
they led to the
well they partly led to the new woke uh
phenomena
because they they didn't realize that
you can't get rid of religion
you can't get rid of rituals you can't
get rid of the problems and
opportunities of identity
all of these things are going to come
back if you try to just if you try to
brush them aside
then they're going to come back in very
weird ways and without you
realizing what's going on you'll have
people kneeling to a shrine of
a man who was killed by police and
putting a halo on his head and
you know and self-mortifying themselves
and doing all kinds of insane
things or that look to you insane but
that you need to understand it's just
it's just this religious impulse gone
gone off the rails
so yes and then the question is what's
the right place for it
that's right you know i've it i've i've
thought in my
i suppose it's a form of comedy that
catholicism is as sane as people get
you know it's baroque right and and god
it's gothic not baroque it's gothic it's
dark it's
it's it's it it has the same
aesthetic in some sense as a horror film
and i'm not being i'm not being
i'm not saying something denigrating by
that i mean it's part of its
strange mystery and all that strangeness
is
necessary because people would be much
more insane without it than they are
with it
it's a container for that religious
impulse and that impulse is to the
to the good yeah and
and the image of the of the crucified
christ
and also the act of communion gathers in
all the extremes together right
it's like if you think of the symbolism
of communion you'll notice that it
gathers in
every extreme from the highest to the
most uh transgressive
all of it comes together it's worth
unpacking that it's ritual
cannibalism in the service of god yeah
yeah but it's also it's also seen as a
as a normal like meal of communion and
it's then also seen
as a as a sexual union
because you there's a relationship
there's a notion in which then
in the altar and in that moment of
communion there's the joining of heaven
and earth you know the
rays of the chalice and there's this
joining which is which is this image of
this
the sexual union between god and the
soul between god and his church
and so all of it it just jammed into
this into
into this ritual as a as a kind of
center of reality would call it
um and so like you said if you get rid
of that then
you're going to have all kinds of
strange factitious versions of it that
are going to pop up
and are going to try to replace it and
it's leading to the fragmentation of our
world and to the breakdown of the west
for sure
so back to this idea of
the the the the mythological level and
the historical level conjoining and i
thought of that as
convenient you know it's that that's a
stumbling point for me
in relationship to the christian story
it's
you say it has to be like this if the
world is constituted
in a good manner and it's the has to be
i mean is that so
just let me say this one thing because
i've been struggling towards it this
whole
it's an act of faith and so let's say
that your faith is
that you decide to make the notion that
reality is good the the cornerstone of
your faith
it's something that you that you what
that you believe or is it something that
you
courageously assume and is there a
difference between that and belief and
if you courageously assume that the
world is good that reality is good
then the touching of the narrative and
the objective in this manner
that's demonstrated by christ that
becomes necessary
is that the idea so
i to me it's funny
i don't see it as an act of faith in the
way that we think of an act of faith
like this jump of faith or whatever i
i see it as an act of trust faith as
trust you would say
that's fine that would be a courageous
assumption if it's trust
and and it's trust in the sense also of
so when we talk about the good we always
have to be careful not to just limit it
to the good to the moral good there
there
is the moral good but when we talk about
the good we're talking about the good in
a in a much larger way
and the good is the the
is the pattern of of the things right
and in the sense that the the fact that
the world
lays itself out as ordered as pattern
inevitably
that there is no way around it you
cannot avoid the order of the world
because
because the in order of you to even
perceive anything it has to have
an identity it has to have a hierarchy
it has to have a margin has to have all
these things it's all there in every
reactive perception exactly and so in
every act of perception
and so it's that every act of perception
presumes a value hierarchy
exactly you can't avoid it and so it's
not so it's not like an act of faith in
the sense that i
i i you know i at the outset think the
world is nihilistic and
and and and chaotic it's like no i don't
i think that
on the contrary i think that you could
say it in a religious way
that the love of god holds the world
together and it's inevitable
that things are held together by these
by these
these patterns of being that are always
aiming towards the good
even in the very identity of whatever it
is that you're
you're encountering
let me ask you something personal then i
mean you
you weren't born an orthodox christian
this is something you came to
how well i think that it has something
to do with what you said before
it does have something to do with the
sense that christianity had fallen away
from its
original story and its original
all-encompassing uh let's say cosmic
narrative
and so it was really i would say in
searching for that and kind of
discovering symbolic thinking on other
fronts and feeling like i was confronted
by this like okay so i can see these
patterns i can see the world through
these
through this coherence and it's like why
is it then that
that christianity doesn't have this uh
and then
then after more looking and more
searching i realized that it did
that not only it did but that some of
the earliest more some of the most
you know powerful early saints talked
about the world exactly this way
you know um and and so when i discovered
that
then i looked around and i saw for
example that iconography
that the relationship between icons and
architecture
and liturgy and and all of this was like
this amazing
giant pattern which was reinforcing
manifesting
making you participate in the way the
world actually
existed and so it was like this kind of
self you know this this
this positive feedback loop i guess you
could say it in a good way where it's
like you
you you you recognize these patterns you
engage in them you
see them you you sing them it's like
this whole thing where you're
engaged um and so i realized that it was
really
in the orthodox church that this was the
most that had been the most preserved
and the most alive
and that i would hear you know
contemporary orthodox
speakers or thinkers or theologians who
talked about the world exactly in that
way
and so i thought okay so this is the
place and also because they kept the
idea of theosis as the ultimate goal
because i think that that's if you know
very very early saint irenaeus which is
you know like
early third century said the logos
became man so that man would become god
that's one of the earth some of the
earliest saints said that you know and
so it's like that's really what
christianity is
and so that's what that's what
ultimately led me to
uh to uh well it is the greatest of all
possible visions
yeah yeah and so i but i think that
you know and i think that it's their
latent even in
in in other forms of christianity and
like one of the things that i've been
trying to do is
how people kind of wake up to that
reality and try to see it wherever they
are how's that going for you
well no i'm really serious i haven't
talked to you for a long time i mean
you've got this i mean you've had a
strange
few years as well i've had a strange few
years as well it's all your fault by the
way
yeah it certainly feels that way
but it's a it's a good it's a good in
that sense i mean
i've i've been surprised in the past
four years since i met you and you kind
of put me on
out there in the world you know um
right now i have with like 90 000 people
following me on youtube
and there's a community of i would say
symbolic thinkers
i'm giving them a place to to uh to
write
like on my on my website i'm putting up
a blog there's communities that kind of
get together and talk about
about this trying to reinvigorate it in
their own communities whether that
wherever it is they come from
and so i've been just non-stop excited
about i mean in a way sad to see that i
think the breakdown of christianity is
is going to continue like you know i i'm
not i i don't have
short-term hope for let's say
the situation but i do believe that
there are
that there are seeds which are kind of
being planted and there are people
who are getting ready and and and will
bear fruit so
so it's been just it's been amazing i
have to say
and thanks for that by the way
i hope i guess you're welcome
to the degree that i had something to do
with it
yeah um
did you want i know one on twitter you
you asked about the virgin birth i don't
know if you want it
if you still have juice if you still
have energy to talk about that
or if or if or sure why not
well the the the one of the things that
is important i would say in christianity
is understanding
that the role that mary has to play
let's say
in the same in the same
in the same way that we talk about how
the reality of christ
came let's i had to manifest itself in
the world for us to understand that
the possibility of this thing the
possibility of how everything comes
together
right in the same way so in for example
in the old testament
you have theophanies you have places
where god and humanity meet
so on the mountain of moses in the
temple
uh in the garden of eden as well so you
have these
they're usually at the top of a mountain
or they're at the end of a temple
okay so it's still a mountain in that so
that's a place where two worlds meet
that's the narrative world and the
objective world really
exactly so the the invisible world and
the visible world the world of of of
logos the world of pattern and then the
world of
possibility right they come together and
then that's when the
the coming together at that point is
where you
see something so it's like that for
everything that's where miracles occur
yeah but actually yeah miracles are like
super events like they
they they show us the pattern of reality
in a more in a in a more concise way but
everything is like that right
so even a chair is a bunch of
possibilities
right that encounters an idea can
encounter the purpose of logos
and then then you have a chair you can't
have just a bunch of stuff or else you
don't have a chair you need that to meet
so at the center of every thing of
everything that exists
there's a little temple a mini temple
and there's a little
incarnation right a little like a mini
one it's not i'm not
i wanna don't want it to seem uh
heretical or anything but there's this
little like mini thing that happens
and so that aspect has a has a a
lower part which is the the nexus of
possibilities the coming together
possibilities
and then this thing that this logos
which comes down so this nexus of
possibilities
you could call it a mountain a house a
temple a body
that's mary
right that's that's her that's she's the
place
of manifestation so she's the
ark of the covenant she's the temple
she's the mountain
she's all of that um and so
and then in and then we play that role
you could say the church the body of
christ we play that role we come
together in love
and then the divine logos descends and
manifests
to unite the body right together and to
reveal himself in that unity of the body
so we see christ
in the unity of love so christ says they
will know you by
how you love each other because that's
how you know that a body exists is that
it's
coherent it holds together as a body um
and so this body
has to be dedicated it has to be
dedicated to the thing which it's
manifesting
so like let's say let's say you have a
turkey
you know uh a car and uh two bits of
grass
and you think i'm gonna make a chair out
of that well it's not gonna happen
right it's not gonna thank you we're
gonna go that route
but that's this is it this is what it's
about it's not gonna happen because
that's not dedicated
and so in the same way of of a a woman
and her husband
so a woman has to be dedicated to her
husband for the union to be
recognized and fruitful so if a woman is
is not
is not faithful to her husband then
there's confusion
on the identity of the child right but
if a woman is dedicated to her husband
which means that she's actually
a virgin to all other
other identities she's virginal to all
other identities and she's dedicated
only to the one thing
so this idea of virginity is super
important because
it's about dedication it's about not
being mixed or not being
uncontaminated uncontamination and so
then you can understand that
in order for something to manifest
the entirety of the whole pattern right
so it's like
so so for for for someone to be the
place of manifestation
for the whole thing well that is what a
mother does
like right it's what a mother does
because she dedicates herself
great to a greater or lesser degree to
bringing someone perfect into being
and the more she loves the more she
dedicates herself to that in every
possible way
so now the virgin mary is the extreme
cosmic version of that
where she has to be perpetual virgin
she is a cosmic virgin she is
perpetually virginal because
she's like you can imagine like in order
for the sun to reflect upon the waters
you know and all those men who don't
believe that sort of thing should take
careful stock of the fact that they're
frequently terrified out of their skull
whenever they encounter someone they're
attracted to
they project that or see it instantly
and it and it
it it demolishes them and then if
they're rejected they're crushed
and you can think of that as a
projection but you can also think of it
as
seeing more deeply what's there and that
you only see that when you're actually
attracted to someone
and then that attraction has a basis
because you're seeing what they could be
even if you're not seeing what's there
and so that's so the that's why the
necessity of virgin birth
because she she is revealing the highest
right she's like the she's like a still
ocean which is on which the sun is
reflecting
and if it was mitigated then it would
only reflect
a mitigated manner and then everything
in between is mitigated like i said it's
like
a woman who's faithful to her husband
obviously he's not a virgin in a
technical sense
you could say she's she's a virginal to
others she's untouched by others but
she's dedicated
to the one man just like well and you
know the degree to which that's
entangled with genuine virginity off
also isn't the k
also isn't so obvious yeah you know it
isn't we don't know what the
preconditions are
for for setting up the ideal
relationship
and and it's certainly the case that we
bring the baggage of our previous
relationships into our current
relationship and maybe sometimes that's
for the better and maybe the virginity
can be symbolic but
people can certainly be sullied by their
past behavior and sometimes in a way
that they can't figure out how to
how to how to repair yeah well for sure
their christian ideal has always been
the the union of virgins in the sense
that then the dedication
ends up being tighter right and so you
are dedicated to your husband and your
husband
is dedicated to you and and then you're
unmitigated mentally even right like in
terms of memories and in terms of
comparing and in terms of
all of these things which we do as human
beings uh and so it it can prevent
slippage in terms of your dedication
yeah so i don't know if that makes sense
in terms of yes
i mean you know these things grasping
these things slips out in and out of my
capacity and
i mean i you you did a lovely job there
of
of of of making a symbolic account for
the
virginity of mary i understand that i
understand
well but no one's going to prove the
virginity of mary historically i mean
that
that's not that's something which is not
that obviously is not possible it's a
secret there's a secret aspect
to virginity which is actually part of
its function
and it's also part of its
how can i say this it's part of its of
its mystery
right which is something which is which
is not public you know it's
it's it belongs to the identity it
belongs to the
you know it's like the the dedication of
something belongs to that which is it's
dedicated right we can talk about this
outside to some degree i mean i
imagine that you wanted to form the
perfect union with someone
let's say it's the perfect sexual union
for that matter
i think that requires love i whenever
i've
had in my life a sexual experience that
wasn't
associated with love
i didn't feel right about it my
conscience bothered me
very much very rapidly and maybe that
makes me an outlier
although i don't think so i think i
think that
that is how people react but they refuse
to notice
now i might be wrong about that maybe
i'm a prude it's possible although i
don't think so
but it's possible but it always struck
me that
sex was best undertaken within the
confines of a committed
of an ultimately committed relationship
that
otherwise it was lesser it was the
lesser
it was less than it should be it was
sullied
and i
now well i don't have anything more to
say about that than that that's been my
experience
and so and i don't know what the
preconditions are for establishing the
perfect marriage let's say and the
perfect marriage would be one that
brought about the best possible children
these are not trivial things they're
very difficult things to get right
certainly you want the least amount of
animosity unnecessary animosity possible
between the parents you want the union
to be tight
you want it to be based on love and
commitment
that seems clear even from the
psychological literature
yeah so i have another question for you
go for it go for it
this idea of theosis
i think it's lack of
i i'm tormented by the possibility that
it's lack of courage that stops people
from
from bringing into being that union with
god
you think
you think that possibility that
possibility there sits there in front of
all of us
and it was actually realized once in
history
well it i would say that at least in the
in the tradition of the church it was
perfectly manifested in christ but
there are there are other saints that
have reached theosis
and that that's what we're all called to
that we're all called to
to become one with god to the extent
that that's
that that's possible well then i guess
we're stuck with the old
problem which is if that's the case then
wha why does the world seem
so unredeemed yeah
well because we're we're distracted you
know with reason
where we we tend to attend to the lower
things
you know we we we get distracted by
our our emotions we get distracted by
all these
things around us that are trying to get
our attention
and then we aim towards these smaller
things
you know we we aim towards whatever it
is right we aim towards making money we
aim towards
uh getting this or having some prestige
and these because
the problem is that these things all
give us us a small sense of satisfaction
and so they they're like little idols i
guess you could call them
um and so we just aim towards these
these
lower things and and that's one of the
reasons why we struggle to see
this higher ideal you know
and so that's one of the reasons why i
guess with one of the reasons for church
as well is that
you know it kind of forces you even if
you're distracted or whatever to come
together at least once a week or
whatever
stand yes together
i know i i understand that
no you know i remember
cynicism that was sort of in the air i
suppose when
the christianity of my youth started to
decompose when people started to
not attend church in droves the cynical
justification in part was well those are
one hour a week christians
how hypocritical can you get to
claim allegiance to this high ideal and
then to go back and live
your tawdry life how could anyone
participate in anything like that and
what we've replaced it with is
never doing it even for an hour a week
which is actually quite a lot of time
compared to none yeah so the replacement
has not been an improvement by any
stretch of the imagination
yeah so and then we we replace it
because we need to
come together and we need to commune and
we need to celebrate and so we end up
doing it in
in these kind of secondary places like
sports or
politics and all these other places you
know we'll
we'll replace that but uh
ultimately like i said one of the things
that help us to trust
let's say or or to find some
respite is that we do it's together like
we're doing this together and so the
exact when you see
there's some comfort in knowing that
that some people
have dedicated their life to god and
have
lived that way and it serves as a
smaller example
but also as a as a comfort in those
moments because usually in the stories
of the saints you'll find
times when they're struggling when
they're they're completely off the rails
when they're not
you know when they're struggling with
thoughts with passions with desires now
you see that in the old testament
stories i mean abraham is all of the all
the patriarchs i mean they lived
full lives complete with catastrophic
failure and and malevolence and murder
and genocide and war and
i mean and and yet we're redeemed
and so i think that that's one of the
things that helps us to
to like you said to to to see
it's like you don't you don't have to
obviously you don't look at the person
who goes to church
once a once a year or whatever that
person has their own thing to deal with
you you
you you find and you see these these
people that are the opposite that really
live and everybody has met i would say
probably a few people like that at least
i've met
a few that are just i've met some
priests
uh monk priests that are glowing like
they're just glowing
and and you see it in their eyes that
they live at a level of
of peace and acceptance that i don't
have access to
and so it's like that type of encounter
is also part of your transformation
because it gives you it tells you like
oh yeah i see it in your eyes like i can
see
that that this exists you know it's not
just something we talk about
i will i want to talk a little bit about
heaven
and so i talked to matt ridley a while
back and
and bjorn lomberg and i'm interested in
their
thinking because they're trying to
plot an optimistic course for the future
one where
at the highest levels of social
integration we
decide how human society
should look at least in so far as
we conceptualize how it might look if we
addressed
some of the major problems that beset us
but it's an attempt and it's an attempt
to make things better it's an attempt to
bring about something
increasingly resembling heaven on earth
i mean
heaven is generally conceptualized you
can conceptualize it as a state of being
it might be the state of being that
those people that you described live in
i've had paradisal experiences
where everything transformed itself into
something that was perfect that appeared
perfect
and i was unable to stay in those
frames of mind the
heaven is that something we build is
that something
i don't understand the relationship be
between the heaven
that awaits us let's say after we die
that's the the idea and what we build
here on earth do those touch is that the
da
is that the doctrine there's so much of
this doctrine i don't understand
at all i think i think a way to to see
it has to do with
with attention again and it has to do
with a hierarchy of attention
if you try to build heaven
you're going to fail you're going to
fail miserably
because you because you're not aiming
high enough
right you're you're aiming and then you
you get stuck in this in these weird
world of opposites that you don't even
understand the side effects of what
you're doing
you know um and so for one person heaven
will look like if everything could be
perfectly ordered then
right and then we know what that looks
like and another person who look at
heaven and think if everything could be
free
if we could all just be free and then
that we know what that looks like
and so the idea is to look higher uh
you know there's a there's a there's a
story that
we have to strive for something better
but then we end up in which users what
you're saying is that we end up with the
tower of babel or we end up with the
flood or we end up with
yeah with the catastrophe continual
catastrophe of un intended consequences
but
as you yourself said we are aiming for
something better so
so the question is how do you person
pursue utopia while avoiding the
pitfalls and that's a theological
question i would yeah it is
and i i think it i know this people are
going to hate that i say this but it it
has to do with worship it's it has to do
with what you worship
so if you worship if you worship those
things that you're aiming towards
the lower things if you worship the the
making a safer society
if you worship them making a freer
society if you worship making
a stronger society all of these things
are going to go off the rails because
they they have unintended
consequences that you don't understand
because they're they're a fragment of
reality you know
they need to be encompassed together in
order to reach something higher
and so that's the danger of ideology
it's the part takes the place of the
whole
so that the the the idea is that if you
actually if you worship god
then those other things will will kind
of lay themselves out
slowly and you won't be able to force
them they'll kind of lay themselves out
slowly and they'll start to manifest
uh you know progressively and and as you
but you have to
attend to the highest or else like i
said
you know and there's a there's even like
a there's an image of antichrist which
is
related to this problem you know uh in
scripture
you could one of the first antichrist
you could say was judas who betrayed
christ
well there's a story with judas which is
very fascinating
because christ doesn't talk to judas
very often but one of the places where
christ talks to judas
is when a woman comes in and
wants to anoint and wash christ's feet
with a very expensive perfume
and then judah says what what are we
doing like why are you doing this you
need to why don't we give this to the
poor
right and christ says you know the poor
will always be with you but
the bridegroom christ the messiah is
there for
a short time yes that's the other kind
of story it's very difficult to
understand how anyone could have
invented that story
like it's not the story of propagandists
no it's
in fact it's the opposite yeah but that
story has to do with attention
so christ obviously isn't saying he
shouldn't help the poor christ has said
to help the poor he said it many times
you have to help the poor give to the
poor of course but he's saying get your
hierarchy in order and you'll help the
poor more effectively that way than any
other
that's that's the case there is that is
the thing it's like it starts with
worship
and the acts that she's doing if you
look at what she's doing
she's first of all she bought something
expensive she's sacrificing it
she's she's sacrificing it to to to bow
down
and to wash the feet to submit to
sacrifice to
and to worship so those three things
like when i talk about the aim how you
end up
having to submit to that aim and so this
is what so christ is saying
first comes worship then the world lays
itself out below that in
an appropriate way and those that's what
the sermon on the mount says too
yeah and those that are are saying help
the poor as their ultimate goal
in the in scripture it says that judas
didn't even want to help the poor he
wanted to take the money for himself
really
like he was a thief actually and he was
taking the money out of the purse
and so those that just want to rejoice
i suppose the truth of the matter is is
that the
genuineness of your desire to help the
poor is precisely proportional to the
degree that you embody christ
that's right and i can't be otherwise it
cannot be otherwise i
i i see that i see that clearly
because otherwise things will go astray
so that's one of the problems with the
modern
projects of utopia is that they're
they're babelesque in
their attempts and you can see like the
type of
gestures that the world authorities are
posing in terms of
in terms of safety extreme like
you know with covet and everything this
desire to create absolute safety
this desire to create absolute
identification and
and tracing and all of these weird these
kind of weird gestures
that show that they think they can
control reality is
is uh it's leading us towards a very
dangerous place
well one of the things i noticed i did
some work on a committee at one point
that was
advising the u.n
in relationship to the establishment of
its millennial goals and there was
hundreds of goals
never not rank ordered and so it was a
tower of babel
because you can't have hundreds of goals
that aren't rank ordered and have any
goals at all
because the goal to have a goal means a
hierarchy something has to be more
important than something else
and there isn't anything more important
than getting your act together
so to speak you know yeah
well i'm going to have to think about
all this a lot
yeah but they're the question that keeps
lurking in in the back of my mind which
is
does the fact that that's how it should
be mean that that's the way that it is
and that's trust that's a question of
trust
yeah yeah it's a
it's a it's a question of trust with
which ends up manifesting itself in
love you know um and i think that
like the love that you have for the
world which is
which is which is clear
anyways it shows me that you might be
closer to that to that trust than than
you might want to admit to yourself
maybe
well i don't know what to do with it i
suppose is the real problem especially
in my current circumstances
yeah i'm i'm i'm the most confused
person i've ever met
i would say yeah
and i've met some pretty confused people
so
well thank you that was really something
yeah you know it's a it's a really a joy
to talk to jordan and
you know like i said there are thousands
of people who are praying for you and
and well they're keeping me alive and
your story isn't
isn't your story isn't over yet you know
so much the pity for me
well you know i i i really all i can do
is really pray that you've
that you yeah that you i don't know how
to
how to formulate it but i i hope that
you
that you that you encounter a moment of
grace and
that you can also find find a
a body to join with
and i'm always here you know like i i we
haven't talked in a few years but
uh obviously you're there's only so much
i can stand
talking to you here
you're you're more you're definitely
always a part of my life you know even
if if it's through
weird youtube videos and everything you
know and and
people remind me that you're a part of
my life all the time because
a lot of people that watch my videos you
know they they come
they come from you they're always they
always start with well i was watching
jordan peterson videos
and so so you're uh you're a gateway to
to uh you're you're a gateway to what
i'm talking about you know so
well that's a good gateway thank you for
the carving
it's beautiful i'm happy to know that
it's there that it's in your house and
let's say michael is uh
is at least holding that dragon at bay a
little bit
we hope yeah
good talking to you yeah it's good
talking to jordan anytime
[Music]
you